welcome to this video yeah it's um close
to close to Christmas and I feel more
like relaxing than um working too much
on uh on videos so what I'm going to do
is to um yeah to do some Blitz kibitzing
hoping for some interesting
games um I mean these kind of videos
always fun to do for me and um not um
not much preparation or or any
nerve-wracking play by myself required
so the first game um I pick up here
right in the middle is um between an
international
Master let's
check Alex say kirf all
right um from Russia um against a German
grandmas um Fabian dling he's a very
strong GM with
25 70 80 90 something like this but he's
not a professional he um has a regular
day job as far as I know and um yeah
still a pretty amazing um strength for
for for Pure
amateur okay so um what do we have in
this position black has got an extra
Pawn he won this with some tactical
tricks on the queen side but um it's not
at all easy to convert it's just a
double B
Pawn and
um White's pieces
are quite okay he doesn't have an
additional weakness somewhere so it will
be difficult for black to um to play for
a win here because the pawn is pretty
much
worthless um yeah white is spending um
lots of time at the
moment I'm not so sure why I mean Knight
takes B4
looks rather normal to me I don't know
what U what else um he is considering
server announcement I still have the
Sounds in always forget to um to turn
them off hope they're not
um coming up too too often okay Bishop
B5
played and now I don't know probably um
just a king move King E7 King F7
something like
this this pin is
annoying Bishop D7 um is not so good
maybe yeah it's a f minute game by the
way um five minute and they um spend
really lots of time on those uh initial
moves
I probably take now on
B4 and Bishop D7 something like this
complete the development or maybe bishop
D7
um immediately so also not too bad I
really wonder about the time I mean it's
a
pretty pretty um yeah
simple position and they spend really
lots of
[Music]
time I mean I'm I'm also always good for
spending useless time
but but
um still with other players it's U it's
quite amazing
here like GM here after 19 moves has
spent four
minutes and only a minute for the rest
of the game and it's uh probably a long
game yeah white is also taking his
time I'm not sure if you if you get in
B4 it's nice but um not sure that you
can
manage so um maybe I would have
retreated The Rook not
[Music]
sure yeah black now has all sorts of
moves maybe Rook C8 or
something hey I guessed one right okay
Bishop G3 is sort of uh a nothing move
with a little time okay yeah black gets
off this uh this bishop on D7 and now if
black manages to exchange the bishop on
A5 for the Knight on
C3 then he will have um yeah I think
pretty decent winning
chances because uh this Knight in in
this kind of um blocked closed position
should be a very good
piece C4 would be a nice Square for for
this
piece yeah now black has got the
A5 I only wonder about the time I mean
he's still spending lots of
time this will get tricky F5 now yeah
fighting for the D5 Square yeah black is
completely winning Knight D5 coming on
G5 F4 and so on the position is uh is
pretty much uh lost for white but
TimeWise it uh it will get get tricky
probably Knight D5 um um
also means that white probably needs to
play Rook B3 to exchange
Rooks yeah or this passive passive
setup that maybe black even manages
white is even even slower
check I mean yeah the black player is an
excellent bullet player I mean he's not
not
slow in general he can he can step it up
here he does and is even ahead on time
now and it's a winning winning minor
piece end
game the three against two on the king
side and you got uh simply the better
piece at the moment the Knight is just
more flexible in this
structure oh it gets tough on time white
suddenly got got very
quick but probably not not quick enough
check check
white on time very very close finish at
the end with the 7900s of the
second no I did I did press follow this
is cool I
mean the the German player here is
really good at um at blitz so it's a
he's got a
very very um
positional strategically profound style
okay okay E3 against the grfa is not
exactly the most aggressive line
but maybe it's
uh not so bad to um to to vary against
this
opening yeah black seems to be a little
bit confused about this at least he
spent some time normal would be to just
castle and then probably play
C5 to open up um the long diagonal you
can also play um yeah C6 I wanted to
say yeah now this is um very similar to
Catalan opening just with revers colors
and white is having an extra piece cd5 I
think it's questionable of does black
have enough compensation
here it's not uh that not that's not
clear to me at all I mean the tempo um
might mean something
C takes D5 yeah exactly what is black
doing
now well quite often you uh you can
sacrifice such a pawn at least in the
Cataline you you often can yeah Bishop
D2 and this uh leads to just an extra
Pawn for
white yeah this was uh this wasn't the
way to
proceed yeah Queen takes C 5 I think
just Rook C1 and uh it's difficult to to
say how how black should save
himself yeah Queen F5 and
then Knight D4 and Bishop B5
curtains yeah and this will be this will
be
played yeah and resigns I think Knight
C6 you can just take Knight C6 and uh
and white wins
a piece and
everything yeah this is also okay I
probably would have taken with the
Knight but black resigned this is also
very very forceful yeah and black black
resigned yeah this is uh interesting
with a
very very
um modest continuation why got a good
position quickly maybe this uh this play
where black was was too um too
aggressive what black can always do is
just Castle first and delay the C5 move
the idea is certainly all right but
you're not actually um forced to play it
immediately you can first castle okay
white after castles here could take on
D5 and play Bishop C4 the old Caris line
but uh still castles should be should be
okay
all right so um I'm still following this
uh the white player but he's not playing
at the
moment I I'll have a quick look if there
are some
um some other interesting interesting
games I've got a new one oh a German
duel yeah the white player is
international Master ker from from
Berlin and um
I think um and maybe I'm not quite sure
if this is correct even he's got
everything together for the Grand Master
title it's also rated above
2,500 so um in in Elo I mean in in real
rating okay we got an advanced
kacan and Knight C3 is uh the sharpest
variation sometimes called the vender V
Shiro variation yeah A6 is um a cute
sideline the idea is if goes G4 now what
he would have played against E6 then
black has got still Bishop D7 in
reserve and this is simply a different a
different
position after G4 white um yeah yeah
Bishop B7 now and the idea is now to
play E6 and
C5 and um yeah just claim that this is a
decent French with um yeah early
expansion on the king side which is more
weakening than um than helping
white but um okay this is
um certainly a viable approach for black
but it's hard to believe that this
should be should be the best really with
A6 and Bishop D7 but um it has been
played by strong um by strong Grand
Masters I think even by kpo and arand
not regular but um they they employed
it okay H5 broke up the the king side
but now black
um had has recaptured with a rook so he
can never Castle short okay maybe he
never intended to but um now it's
definitely out of out of the
picture and yeah black played C5 getting
counter play you see that black is um
somewhat behind in
development and um this is one issue
with this setup of course it it's very
time consuming white however had a
misplaced Knight on C3 and um he
rerooted this to to G3 which also cost
to to tempy but allow it to play C3 to
um support the
center yeah here black um is I think in
a little bit of a dilemma he doesn't
want to take on on D form opening up the
the C file early he would like to play
Knight C6 probably but then white would
I think just take on C5 and enjoy an
extra Pawn so it's not clear what black
should do now yeah the an he
took yeah what you like to do is to
exchange the light Square Bishop but I
don't know if Bishop B5 is maybe just
too slow not
[Music]
sure the the bishop B5 white also might
consider just to play Bishop
[Music]
G2 and um I'm not
sure yeah this is um
the yeah the sensible move just get
getting out some
pieces black also um can consider to
play G6 of course to um prevent
F5 in the long run okay on F5 black now
can just take
but F5 is the yeah the principled to
break in this
position uhuh interesting Bishop B5
still the idea another idea could be to
rroo this Knight C8 B6 C4 this kind of U
maneuver yeah Bishop B5 is uh was the
plan at
least I don't know I would play I think
G6
now I would I would be getting nervous
about this F5 move
maybe yeah maybe uh it's not a real
threat but I think
um it's probably a good idea to get rid
of it maybe maybe Knight F5 here yeah
taking on F5 GF is not too bad the H
Pawn um is not promoting so quickly it
will go to H5 but um H6 is formly
covered and now the center is completely
closed maybe black has got ideas now of
Knight C6 and then
A5 this kind of uh
plan or A5 immediately but then maybe
A4 not sure I
probably would um prepare
this bishop C4 is also also an
idea uhhuh this is interesting okay yeah
maybe he's planning kn C8 to B6 I
mentioned this idea before but of course
as long as the the queen is on B6 is not
possible yeah Knight C8 would
be the logical followup but uh maybe A4
then yeah no another idea would be
B5 but black B5 and then
A5
yeah should black um should white take
on C4 he
didn't yeah Knight C5 looks
normal h
not sure why um white is not playing
this okay Bishop
D3 yeah now probably
A5 breaking up the queen
side
yeah black looks fine but the position
is still still very complicated there's
all kinds
of missteps possible I guess they always
consider that both kings are potentially
weak not at the moment they're both um
secured by by own pawns and this Pawn
chain in the center but um if um the
position opens up both Kings can can get
in trouble
yeah but now white um simply has a
problem with his Queen side he certainly
doesn't want to take on A5 and U yeah
this this gives up the B4
Pawn Yeah I think black should now just
take
it yeah this is
um a very very big Advantage for black
he's got everything nicely covered the
bishop on
C4 is um is strong with pawns on B5 and
D5 and um he can activate pieces on the
aile moves like Queen A5 or just pushing
the B Pawn are
coming yeah the B Pawn maybe or Bishop
B4 it's also
strong yeah black has um a completely
winning position by
now he just uh attacks the D4 pawn and
now maybe
B4 yeah the time is of course a big
concern and
um check white has launched the a the H
Pawn to
A7 and
um Bishop E2 actually I think wins the
queen it doesn't have any
squares but okay it's it's easy to tell
from the yeah from the on the side
without the the time
pressure
yeah black black is still I think just
winning maybe just to Queen G4 oh this
is stronger just take
it
check H this Knight is still slightly
irritating oh the time the double check
but um check probably uh not
dangerous 5 Seconds both check uh
oh
check
check black forfeits on
time yeah a shame I mean white was
completely uh completely dismantled in
this game he didn't have uh any chance
but black was just um just too slowly
just to slow
okay and he left the server obviously
slightly annoyed about this game so
let's check uh what else is uh what else
is on
there
um we have um 31
game two grand Masters um playing here
disintegrator
is from uh this is Serbia right from
Serbia and officer here is
from
um aan right farit
abasov 25 something
ELO okay so uh let's um check what's
going on this game it's a 3-1
game and
um we've got equal material white has
some
um space advantage on the queen side the
Knight on A6 is somewhat somewhat
strangely placed but Dwight also has
some some some bad pieces Bishop on D2
is not too
great and um he's played F4 which um of
course prevents any E5 move but also
weakens E4 and G4 okay the question is
um what can white do against um the
Knight on A6 which is really um the
problem
here so um I don't know uh what what
exactly is white doing now against
um against nigh
C5 uh this is interesting the queen
doesn't have any Square to prevent
Knight takes
C5
yeah Knight takes
C5 or am I blind here or something ah
okay white can take C7
probably maybe you can make maybe you
can play C6
first C6 Rook somewhere and then
um
okay yeah the same the same idea Knight
takes C5 now yeah yeah white somehow um
Tangled himself up a bit with with his
pieces and um yeah now black has won the
C5 pawn and he can play Knight E4
because D2 is hanging so he gets uh gets
it back the
piece yeah now black is just a pawn up
and um he's got this great Square on
e4 so black should have a clear
Advantage unless white um get C7 back
quickly yeah this looks good Queen B2 or
something activating the
queen oh what's this ah Rook C7 is the
idea
interesting but there's a there's a
check on B1
also
check Knight C1 and now just rook f8 and
over oh okay yeah white continues a bit
but this is just um just a piece for for
nothing and 50 seconds is is enough the
position is also
quite um yeah quite easy to
play yeah Rook
A2 no okay need to be a bit cautious
yeah this is
good
check check
yeah this is a m job just just take
everything and white resigns just be
careful that you you don't get
checkmated on the back rank this is
could this could
happen Okay so who's who else is on
there we've got
um let's let's have a look I'm looking
at uh a very long list here of uh of
games
well this is a this is a very high rated
match um Golden Eagle as black we had
him
before winning in somewhat lucky fashion
against uh against um Grand Master dling
and um white is resign SEF it's a nice
name it's a pretty new account I don't
know who this
is it's not in it's not in the finger
notes but he's got two
2,730 on the F minute rating pool which
um pretty much means that U he must be a
very strong
GM so okay what what do we have here we
have
um a trpovski
check and U white is banking on his good
development but uh black has got two
Bishops and um Frankly Speaking I think
black should should be should be in good
shape
here the question is yeah A6 probably a
knight A3 I don't see any any other move
and then just take King E7 the question
is then Bishop takes F7 but then maybe
just Rook f8 Rook F2 yeah this is the
thing take on A3 King E7 and Bishop F7
is answered by Rook f8 yeah and this
means that black is uh is just better
here
he's got the better Pawn
structure and um there's no yeah this is
just just a bad
move why open up the position with black
getting on the second rank
quickly okay this was the concrete idea
okay yeah maybe this wasn't so
bad E5 is hanging I don't know how to
how how to protect
this
[Music]
yeah I think black cannot protect it I
mean maybe it's
not it's not so
um so much of an
issue H yeah I don't know looks a bit
tricky
check yeah black gave up this
Pawn it's
um probably not U not a big deal I mean
the bishop on C6 is fine and The Rook on
F2 is fine attacking on the second rank
so maybe it is not
uh not terrible for
black he will get get a pawn back very
um very likely I would like to know who
this guy is I do do a quick quick
background check if
uh there is a site that um can help with
this
questions let's see if uh if it got any
information about
this resign have
[Music]
no
no information about this I have no idea
who this guy is okay so
um let's check the game again black um
has gotten back a Pawn on H2 check and
um still retains this active Rook
position and uh very this this
configuration is on the queen side is
just very good you might lose the C Pawn
but the bishop on C6 capes everything
together and black can try
to attack the F5 and G4 Pawn um and also
you can just play a king king to D6 to
uh to cover the
pawn yeah maybe Rook G8 then
H yeah black can always give checks on
H2 and so on if
um and
maybe yeah I'm not not quite sure what
uh what black should do king D6 Rook G8
yeah maybe give some checks but the
checks um white can just Advance with
the
King and I'm not quite sure um now black
should defend the G
Pawn yeah this is another another way to
go just play Maybe G6 now get rid of the
pawns Rook F7 Rook
F7
ah he overlooked F6
H yeah and this Pawn promotes
unfortunately yeah very tricky play by
white now promoting this
Pawn yeah no idea who this guy is it's
he's got the Spain flag but this is um
completely
um yeah random I mean you can set up
your flag how
just how you like it and U he could be
from from Spain but also from I don't
know Antarctica or something
everything's
possible
um yeah but he's probably very strong
grandm okay but okay the game is uh not
completely over um I just saw that these
two pawns you can still still try as
black but the bishop usually is a good
piece to to stop
pawns and black is just uh down to 15
seconds so um this shouldn't
be shouldn't be
um a problem for white yeah just take on
G2 C7 and this thing is uh promoting
Rook G8 Rook B8 and
over
check Che yeah of course Black is Black
is still giving a couple of checks but
just
C8 no C8 would have uh gotten to checks
black resigned yeah he just just in time
he
resigned yeah okay maybe try to follow
this re resign SE
guy so always a shame if you don't know
who this is I mean it could be anybody
but uh it's obvious that he's he's very
strong but you don't know who it is
let's look at at the history he's got 19
out of 20 in the last game in the last
couple of
games yeah and if you look at this here
you can look at the history he's always
playing let's say half a dozen games and
then then
leaves so um and how many did he play
today four games one won them all three
minute 1 minute 3 minute 5 minute okay
yeah maybe um one or two more games
would be would be
nice I'll wait
for let's say Max maximum half a minute
and if he doesn't start a new game or
gets a new game with the with the five
minute or any other pool then
um
oops got a call
here um okay so let's let's look is
there ah okay this is cool a new three
minute game
um resign have against
Yardbird this is Grand Master Eric lron
from originally from Germany he's got
the Estonian flag I think his his um
girlfriend is from
Estonia okay so let's see what what's
happening here we've got a sideline the
Queen's uh Queen's Pawn
opening and um
black um quickly attacked the the the
Knight and um occupied the center white
probably will play Knight C3 and E4 to
open it
up and get some play in the center okay
maybe still E4 don't
know takes on C3 takes on D5 okay but
this is certainly okay Bishop E3 yeah
black probably needs to return to d8
okay yeah why not why not Queen d8 um
wasn't the most active move
ever yeah well white has got um somewhat
strange um strange pieces here on on B3
C3 and E3 you you you really need to
play E4 or C4 to open open the
position and um yeah maybe just drop
back now Knight C5 wasn't really a good
yeah or let's say it it doesn't spoil
anything but you also don't have any big
benefits from this
move yeah white now at least got rid of
one of
the strange pieces that I mentioned and
now you can play E4 next move and
actually have a slight
Advantage at least a slight Advantage
because you're opening up the
position especially for the G2 bishop
and um this
way should should be somewhat better
black has this somewhat sorry piece on
C8 while white um was trying to open up
the diagonal yeah this is um now a
concrete issue how about how to defend
the D4
Pawn yeah probably just Knight
C5 and um a possibility is to continue
with Knight D3 and then F4 this kind of
this kind of
setup H F4 is aggressive
but what about Knight
G4 Knight G4 to E3 looks um looks um
tricky yeah Lon is a very um the black
player is a very aggressive
player always need to be very cautious
and I played him I don't know so often
over the years and uh you um you you can
be sure that you will find some
interesting uh tactical possibilities
even in the the strangest of positions
sometimes he just um yeah plays um plays
strange and strange stuff and this is
worse but it's
very oops I'm getting a
call
hello uh no no problem at all and let
let me call you back on Skype I'm just
doing a video it's no no no
problem I call back I call back it's no
big deal all
right
okay I just got got a funny call here um
yeah I really should turn off the the
phone yeah in the meantime white white
just won the game I'm sorry about that
but uh yeah what happened here somewhat
somewhat uh drastic oh no we got a new
game yeah I'm sorry I hope you followed
this
um on your own so to say um I got um I
got this call that I need to take I
didn't didn't know who it
was so um yeah we got a king king side
fianchetto here maybe um going for um
Kings indan and uh this is 3 minute and
3 minute he's got also close to
2,600 against Grand Master from Israel
let's let's check quickly I'm Maxim Rin
he's also 26 something guy okay we've
got um a
kingside fianchetto and uh with E7 and
D7 Knights it's not the greatest of uh
setups but okay it's a Blitz game Knight
G5 was interesting but
[Music]
um Knight G5
yeah white somehow doesn't want this
move night G5 I thought would would be
would be a good
idea Knight F6 take on E5 take on d8 and
Knight B5 stuff like that this is one
drawback of this Knight
position
so Knight G6 yeah strengthening the E5
point and intending to play
F4 yeah this
[Music]
um yeah this looks a bit shaky for
black to be honest maybe Knight F6 and
then Bishop
H6 but um okay this is the kind of
position that looks shaky but if white
doesn't um
yeah use any of this in the next couple
of moves then black can easily um be
better even with the
center yeah I mean maybe black is fine
you can just play um C6 yeah exactly C6
Queen
E7 Queen E7 G7 stuff like that and then
decide yeah Queen E7 probably okay for
first this um yeah maybe this is better
you you're not quite sure where the
queen
belongs but now you've got uh got many
ideas you can play Knight E5 at some
point or just complete development
Bishop E6 Rook d8 all good natural moves
but okay you can also think about direct
um direct
moves maybe E3 for example can be an
idea yeah
E3 yeah this can get um ugly very
quickly like Fe Queen takes and then
F4 and uh well All Black's pieces are on
the king side and white has got a rook
on A1 and and so on I mean not exactly
helping the
king yeah maybe F4 or
something I'm not
sure yeah okay well I'm not not too bad
today with guessing all those moves
maybe Knight G4
yeah I'm good with
guessing yeah this is this is terribly
dangerous I mean maybe maybe even
winning F2 is a just a a huge threat and
you've got Knight E5 Bishop F5 and so on
yeah white simply
um yeah got kicked around here in this
game
yeah Queen F3 is Checkmate
even and uh not sure how to prevent
this yeah Queen F3 made I
mean this is uh this is a really a real
beating white resigned yeah no move I
see no move move to to to cover this
yeah very strong play by
black and very um yeah very forceful I
mean no it doesn't look like
um he he he he didn't stand any chance
in this
game okay let's hope um this resign s
guy plays uh plays another
game I'll wait 30 seconds and if it
if a new game hasn't started then then
I'll choose some some other
one yeah um this will be the last uh
video before Christmas it's one day
before Christmas today and over
Christmas I have some things to do
visiting family and things like this so
I probably won't make a video maybe if
I'm home and I have the time I'll do
something quick but certainly not
um some longer videos that require lots
of time to
produce all right so a new game resigns
have against horse the
white and um yeah I've got um the Trump
again I don't think um this guy has
something in the profile
feeder rating no feeder rating 2,100
USCF but a very good three minute rating
so it's probably good at good at blitz
so um we have a Gambit he played F3
E4 and this is uh quite similar to the
to the black m m Gambit with D4 D5 E4
but this looks uh looks much better in
comparison
white white is just a bit quicker and
black has this
server quite weird Knight on D6 which
hampers
development yeah and H5 is a threat of
course yeah F6 is of course very very
ugly just long castles
now yeah and then something like let's
say G5 Bishop H3
[Music]
and um yeah black has um black has real
problems this is just a fantastic
compensation for the
pawn yeah probably it's it's G5 Bishop
H3 looks like the normal way to proceed
yeah activating this
bishop okay this is also very direct
maybe H6 coming or
G6 yeah this is um probably even even
better than KN than Bishop to
H3 yeah okay G6 is not possible at the
moment but all right now this move yeah
what what what should black play even
here it's U cannot really
um go
yeah yeah I don't know this is playable
just take on
F6 okay yeah this is just the the
positional way to do it just block on E6
and black will never ever
develop this threatens Bishop D6 and
queen
[Music]
B7 also H6 uh G6 is threatened and oh
God yeah this is this must be this must
be
over cannot believe um black is able to
defend
this yeah I can just
um yeah Knight D5 and and E7 next
move if there's not you can also take on
F6 yeah yeah it's a multiple
multiple
wins yeah take on G7 is the
easiest oh this yeah whatever every move
wins I'm a bit surprised that black is
not resigning actually this really
doesn't make much
sense
black resigns yeah now it's a rook down
Rook E7 Queen C6 and take on E7 white is
just an extra
Rook yeah the position after like 10
moves was just uh
overwhelming this is much more than um
enough compensation for a
pawn yeah how did this um happen let's
look
briefly uh this move okay and then
[Music]
E4 yeah probably you you should just go
to
F6 and
um I don't know I
this yeah this this might be enough for
a
pawn the way he he played it was very
quickly more than enough this is now
tricky okay
so let's um hope for another
game yeah this guy is really
exceptionally exceptionally strong at
least at at
Blitz it's a very strong GM
probably all right let's um have a look
at um the video length we about on 50
minutes okay um so I'm not sure if he
will will start another
game if I wait
um I'll I'll start another one here or
let's say I switch to another one you've
got the golden eagle here again against
arm composer I think and if Robert Hof
shanan I think he's
um 2 six something ELO yeah very strong
GM and we have a very uh double-edged
position out of the moroy bind where
black took on
C3 but um he's got strong pieces on B7
Knight on C5 and potentially The Rook on
G8 could be used against um the white
king okay
okay um given the the choice I I prefer
prefer this guy let's let's close the
other he was just too impressive in
these other games so playing against the
German international Master let's have a
look yuran pisham I don't know him I
mean I know the name but I don't know
him
personally okay so we again have some
kind of Kings side
fianchetto and uh yeah this
um shouldn't be too bad for for black
got um the blocked Center black has the
opportunity now to play Bishop H6 if he
wants yeah getting rid of the the bishop
it's not clear that this is always a
great
idea from a pure um
strategical point of view um this is the
bad Bishop but sometimes it has a really
useful
roles okay but uh still black has a good
good structure now
yeah he's um playing this
um castling by hand and now probably A5
A5 Knight
C5 or maybe some some moves on the king
side first to prevent white from getting
a too good
position okay first win a Tempo on e4
and then probably
A5 one problem with this kind of A5
setup if you want to go this like this
check
is um that it is solid but it it's not
um the kind of setup that helps you to
open lines against the king it's very
passive in a way it just holds the queen
side so he didn't he didn't go for this
yeah H5 but black intended
H4 okay is he really going for
B5 I don't know B5 white can play
C5
yeah black is um banking on a king side
attack Queen C3 is a threat easy to see
though and
um okay he tries to get uh D6
back yeah black has somewhat weakened
Pawn structure of course C6 and A6 are
weak but he's got a strong Bishop on E6
and he's got the B
foul so
um this is certainly um I would say
easier to play for
black than for white maybe the position
itself is not such a big deal for for
white
uh oh Bishop takes A2 now is a is a big
threat the queen is not protected on E3
this is um a problem I but maybe bishop
A2 King
[Music]
A1 white
resigns hm
H yeah I think this this wasn't
necessary
really is there I I'm not sure is there
some
threat I mean okay you you let's say
here how does
um how does black win
now if you if you go here you can just
play this and the king the queen is
hanging and the and the bishop is
hanging so the queen moves then I can go
here but it is trapped
right yeah well maybe he didn't he
didn't see
something um yeah okay this is difficult
but you can play Rook C2 instead of
resigning this is the only feasible move
anyway
probably Rook D2
maybe no I don't think I can I can take
this back now okay yeah okay so some
entertaining games by this uh
mysterious guy
here and he's still uh locked on so
maybe uh we see another game I'll just
uh I'll just do the do his games until
he locks
off and um maybe complete a one hour
video why
not
yeah the point I was uh trying to make
here in in this kind of position if you
play A5 which looks uh nice to to get
this Knight secured then you don't have
much chances to open up the the queen
side for
counterplay and uh though you're looking
looking fine strategically with the good
bishop and um and this this Knight which
looks looks nice on C5 you don't have
any uh any concrete way to proceed he
was playing for
B5 in this position he realized I guess
that B5 is answered by
C5 and this is why you play this move
threatening B5 to um okay nice match
up so we've got arm composer this this
guy from am
minia against um our mystery
player and again some King side
fianchetto okay we've got F4
coming oh E5 is uh I think
rare Knight F3 is the
overwhelming main move I don't know
what's what's going
on okay I think now is this the position
where white can play
H4 yeah probably what black has castled
yeah I don't I don't know this opening
it is very sharp
obviously white has pushed an early E5
but black has got counterplay with
C5 my first impression without um really
knowing this is that uh this looks a bit
like white has overextended um how does
he keep a center now Queen D4 Knight C6
I don't know
or queen D4 castles and then Knight C6
maybe this is even
better how does he keep um this Pawn on
E5 I don't know maybe he confused
something okay but I I really don't know
don't know this uh this opening maybe we
in some Theory and I don't know
it okay Knight G5 was just answered by
castling
maybe maybe E6
now Knight
C6 yeah yeah I don't know I mean my
suspicion is that this is uh just
incorrect for white but in the Blitz
game you never know it um it can be can
be
dangerous black black looks fairly
fairly solid to
Me Maybe Knight D2 E5 attacking the
bishop yeah probably Bishop
B3 you don't want to give up this this
piece this is
the the strongest is the attacking piece
so Bishop B3
looks looks
normal does it have a serious drawback I
don't
know yeah Queen A5
probably now Bishop
B3
maybe Knight G4
something
[Music]
H yeah Bishop B6 looked uh strange to me
white couldn't take I guess but this was
a bit happening a bit too quickly for me
to to to
understand okay but um what's going on
here black has got an extra Pawn let's
uh start with the simple things and he's
got this this Knight on E5 which covers
um F7 very
reliably yeah this this Knight on E5
just uh keeps the whole position
together
Knight G4 looks looks strong to
me attacking this this bishop and then
maybe if it leaves um let's say to C1 or
something Knight D4
attacking C5 B5 and so
on yeah don't know where to go Bishop F2
looks very very uh
yeah without
any
[Music]
idea yeah this black player is a very
tough customer why didn't have the
slightest chance in this
game yeah I hope it's um it's a real
human
player if if you got this kind of uh
complete destruction games you sometimes
ask yourself okay is this a human
playing so unfortunately a sign of the
times yeah I can just just grab on
F2 and maybe take B5 is is there a
threat okay maybe take and Knight
E6 uh this is this is strong if you yeah
he just covered F7 and now if the Knight
moves from B5 there's a bishop D4
winning the queen and this is just a
piece Queen Knight
D4 and B5 or B6 or
something quite looks completely winning
yeah yeah complete thrashing of the
white
player I don't know it looks it looks
like this is um probably a top 50 player
or something very good very good what is
it looks it looks very very very
good like um the opponents have zero
chance I'm not quite sure also it
doesn't look very computer is from my
taste but
um you you you never know but IC usually
has a pretty good A good um anti-
cheating system it's very rarely that
people can cheat for a long time
there yeah all right this video is now
more than 1 hour long and
um yeah well I'm still curious about
this
guy okay maybe I try to wait for one
more game but I definitely uh finish
this video
um if he if he is
leaving would be uh somewhat reassuring
where If he if he you would lose the
game make sure that he
human yeah 27 on on the first minute
pool is
um it's really outlandish it's very very
rare that you see
this I want to have a quick look at this
bishop E6 move I don't um can
I I can I can enter examine mode
okay
let's have a look I want I want to check
quickly Bishop E6
Fe of course now the queen is
attacked and um yeah where does it
go H this so bad for white I mean yeah
the problem is how do you
Castle yeah this is the
issue black can can play um just just
like know something like this attacking
attacking C2 with a check it's got this
possibility of course okay need to be
cautious
G6 it's um it's a pawn you you would
like to protect of course but how um is
white going to get his King out of the
middle not at all
probably something like this probably
runs into this move
[Music]
here Queen G6 isn't isn't
possible yeah this was very strong
Bishop E6 killing off um this bishop
which was White's best attacking
attacking piece and this is a really
strong move I mean you need to uh
be
very alert to find such a move because
it's such it's very counterintuitive to
allow this this double pawns but it's
actually really strong if you look now
the f file is open you control D5 so
there's never any Knight coming to D5
what's what's bad is of course that E4
is
um it's an eternal post for the night
but uh this is not important some
because the concrete factors are much
more more important you've got Knight B4
Knight C4 all this stuff and how does
white defend probably not at all yeah
very strong play yeah but he's not
starting a new game
unfortunately I'll check um what else is
happening on the
server maybe I can can start or look
at
um I'd like to have some game which
isn't exactly on move 60 or
something maybe
[Music]
I'm we've got the here Renegade against
arm
composer was
Renegade
supposedly a 13year old
Canadian rasan prou I don't know this
person if he's really that old then 2445
is very
impressive okay um what do we have
here um black has lost castling
rides oh here he took with a d Pawn this
looks like a
yeah well what can I say just
nonsense
check and um here black looks uh to be
in in some trouble Knight G4 okay okay
maybe it's not so bad Knight G4 intense
Bishop
C5 and H5 H4
now
okay it's probably not so bad
yeah maybe F5
now trying to exchange some
pieces especially uh this Knight on G4
which is really an annoying
piece F5 and Bishop moves and take on G4
take on D6 it's maybe not too
bad
yeah white is uh spending really huge
amounts of time for this I mean it's a
five minute game not three minute he
spent more than four minutes um up to
this point and this um the moves played
before weren't exactly difficult so uh
quite quite
surprising okay E5 mhm
of course this is um much more
aggressive way to play than uh the thing
that I
suggested maybe bishop C5 uh maybe
bishop C5 here and then H4 this could be
[Music]
strong yeah well Bishop C5 needs to be
played anyway I'm not quite sure what
black is spending time on okay maybe
take on E5 but Bishop C5 looks just um
just normal
check yeah now H4 with the idea Bishop
G4 take on
G3 after H4 um I think I don't see what
white is
playing can take on F6 maybe now take on
on G uh G3
right
check ah check yeah this is this is even
stronger now the bishop is just trapped
on G3 I didn't see this at all but the
the fun thing is that both Bishops on G4
and C5 protect D7 E7 so white doesn't
have a check and he doesn't have a move
really white resigned yeah he's resigned
just before he overstepped the time
limit yeah fortunately I don't get
another game here by this um resign s
guy which was really impressive to watch
yeah anyways um this is um 70 minute
video now so um if you're watching this
on on Christmas day while you're waiting
for I don't know relatives to arrive or
something we've got some long video to
um to watch hope you enjoyed it and I'll
be back after
Christmas have a good time with with
your family and
friends